the zero tolerance policy is gone but
the damage remains from one of the trump
administration's most
controversial and widely condemned
immigration actions
the deliberate separation of children
from their parents at the border
we have impacted in a way that i think
we will not fully understand an entire
generation
of children um thousands of them
and there is no clear remedy
right now for that at a minimum more
than 5 500
children were separated from their
parents beginning in 2017.
audio recordings of children crying
emerged
and helped lead to a public outcry
and the hasty abandonment of the policy
but approximately 600 children still
have not been reunited according to a
lawsuit
filed by the american civil liberties
union i think it really was a matter of
they just didn't care all they cared
about is taking the children away
put no plan in place to track their
children didn't even think about the
fact that the families
would someday need to be reunited in
most cases parents were deported to
their home countries
in mexico or central america and the
children put into foster care
some of the younger kids have forgotten
their parents as the years passed by
others are deeply traumatized one of the
things we're seeing is that the children
are so
angry and resentful at their parents
asking their parents
can you love me enough to keep me why
didn't you stop them from taking me away
the family separation policy was
deliberately planned to deter
migrants if you are smuggling a child
then we will prosecute you and that
child may be separated from you
as required by law a department of
homeland security inspector general's
report found the border patrol and
immigration officials
were unprepared for the zero tolerance
policy
and kept unreliable and incomplete data
on children and parents immigration
advocates hope president joe biden's
task force on family separations
succeeds
in reuniting the remaining parents and
children
but they say those families deserve more
give them permission to
come to the united states to rejoin
their children the united states and
then to give them legal status
and create some type of restitution fund
advocates also want a full investigation
and strict policies to ensure that the
cruelty at the border
never happens again rob reynolds al
jazeera
los angeles